bloomberg businessweek cover story this
week profiles the Republican
presidential candidate and Empire
Builder Donald Trump it's a capitalist
character story as only Bloomberg's max
Abelson can write he joins us now max
welcome you say in your profile quote in
the same way that Trump's campaign is
post politics his company is post
business what do you mean by business
okay so the idea of being post politics
I guess you know if Tom keen we're gonna
run for president which I don't
theoretically lord save us I know he
would have to have things like you know
you'd have to have policies and he would
probably have to have a little bit of
public service under his belt and he
would probably need to be very polite
which Tom keen is very good at and he
would have to be prepared you prepare
for the debates Donald Trump the amazing
thing about his political stuff is that
he has soared to the top of the
Republican field without really without
any of them business that's what I was
interested in so I had a lot of fun sort
of putting all politics to the side and
just diving into business because after
all this guy's a businessman that's why
he's well-known that's why he is what
you learn what's a major take away from
your wonderful article everybody's
talking about it
this guy today is just not a skyscraper
builder he does not put up skyscrapers
his business is something else entire
business is playing a businessman on TV
you know what that's a good question the
answer is that's not true rather just
because what he says he is isn't what he
is so he has this really big folio
exactly although his dad Fred Trump had
like Queens and Brooklyn apartments
Donald has bigger stuff we can talk
about it then he has golf and I have to
say I sort of toward the the Trump
Empire with some of his deputies we went
to bed Minster together and then and
then he licenses stuff like buildings
and products and he manages hotels and
his good deal maker is he a masterful
CEO well listen I mean the fun thing for
me about learning about his career is it
is really complicated it has ups and has
downs and he fell really low but then he
rebounded so this man is throwing a lot
of darts at a dartboard well he would
say you know that's a crazy question on
you know this is this is all according
to plan but you know when you look at
what what his career looks like he rose
really really high in the 80s in fact he
had a sports team york generals right
you don't know that oh yeah oh yeah
generals it was a non NFL football team
okay that's so the 80s was
a lot of borrowed money in fact he
personally guaranteed some of the
borrowed money which became a problem
later the 90s when that when that conned
me what he survived he didn't personally
go bankrupt though his casinos did and
he managed to pull together with kind of
a new type of business now that you've
met with him and talked to him and
written about him is he gonna go after
you on Twitter what does your future
look like now well I hope my future is
relatively somewhere into my past my
present because I feel like I did a fair
job I tried to go into this and explain
he's old he's getting great numbers at
least right now is he authentic
I think authenticity is like the thing
he has I'm not sure I've ever met
someone who seemed more the rap on this
guy it was given to him by his father
what did you learn about what you know
and there's rich people that get things
from their parents and then they do
better or they move on further can you
say that of mr. Trump listen what he
inherited first of all he inherited a
lot more money than we did I think
depending on you your guy's parents but
what he inherited though was this outer
borough real estate empire and what he
did was he brought it into Manhattan and
what happened afterwards is complicated
but I guess you have to give him credit
for that
okay all right Mike Samuelsson thank you
so much it's a fantastic read in the
latest issue of Bloomberg Businessweek
which is available online today and will
be on newsstands tomorrow Trump finally
talks